est-ce que c'est un vrai sujet merci
Fabrice
[Applaudissements]
pardon
j'espère quand même que les députés
n'ont pas été élus pour régler des
comptes personnels avec des animateurs
en ce moment on trie des jeunes patients
des bébés parce que les médecins tirent
la sonnette d'alarme il y a plus de
place il y a voilà on a effectivement du
personnel soignant non vacciné qui voilà
vous connaissez le sujet il y a de
l'autre les Français qui se prennent la
hausse de l'essence les Français
disaient les députés de la majorité
parlementaires sont en burn out j'ai lu
ça ce matin sur France Info on mérite
mieux quand même enfin je veux dire on
mérite mieux la France va pas bien
Jean-Louis Boyard il a été élu il
incarnait une jeunesse effectivement une
certaine fraîcheur et qu'est-ce qui fait
il utilise sa fonction de député pour
régler des comptes personnels il a
changé quatre fois de version on
comprend plus rien ce qu'il veut
qu'est-ce qui veut j'aurais aimé qu'il
soit là ce soir juste pour lui poser
cette question tu
vois
ok sa révolutionnaire s'il veut mais il
avait tout le loisirs de la faire quand
il était chroniqueur ici il peut quand
il a été député il avait qu'à le faire
là en fait c'est vous qui est d'employé
il y a
c'est vous monsieur qui avait employé
l'expression je crois sur Tik Tok que
j'aime beaucoup il dit vous avez ah il a
hacké l'émission en fait l'expression il
a piraté l'émission en fait c'est un peu
l'idée en fait il est venu faire son
truc il avait prévu son truc
manifestement et il est venu imposer son
sujet il a juste pas compris qu'en fait
l'émission c'était pas lui qui la
faisait ça c'est le premier point il y a
un deuxième point puisqu'il s'intéresse
tant au milliardaire je trouve ça
extraordinaire que ce monsieur aille
chez le groupe Altice tout le week-end
chez BFM donc chez dry qui est un proche
d'Emmanuel Macron et dont quand même
rien contre lui on peut jamais je m'en
fous mais c'est pas le problème
tout contre tout le monde mais le truc
c'est pas ça c'est qu'à un moment donné
aussi tu vois c'est pas un point de
cohérence il veut qu'on s'intéresse à la
à la problématique des liguettes on peut
s'interroger raisonnablement sur la
ligne éditoriale je rappelle quand même
que la directrice des programmes sur BFM
a quand même dit à propos de la pandémie
que au fond elle a suivi la ligne
officielle pour ne pas perturber la
cohésion sociale chez moi ça s'appelle
de la propagande mais en réalité et je
termine là-dessus il y a un point qui
est intéressant chez Louis voyeur il a
dit un truc cet après-midi en conférence
de presse que je suis pas sûr d'avoir
bien compris il dit je dépose plein
d'autres cyranoa ok bah si tu veux c'est
la tête droit fais-le je veux dire et
derrière il dit et je pense et pour les
millions de Français qui ont été
insultés lorsqu'il a invité l'extrême
droite qui a tenu des propos racistes
qualifié c'est fini moi ce que j'ai
envie de dire juste sur ce point c'est
mon garçon termine tes études de droit
quoi
merci à partir de la troisième année que
tu commences à un peu de cohérence mais
là il y a un problème je comprends rien
à ce qu'il dit qu'est-ce qu'il veut mais
il est récidiviste
monsieur Jean-Marie moi Géraldine mais
on en parle pas monsieur maintenant
d'abord les yeux exorbités donc ça c'est
déjà pas jouable du tout il y a un
moment il m'a fait penser à moi
c'est à dire très très con quoi et on
n'écoute plus un mec qui est en colère
c'est pour ça que j'ai arrêté Sacha
Guitry un jour il avait reçu un comédien
qui était arrivé un peu en retard c'est
mis en colère et après il s'est dit
j'étais tellement moche que je ne me
mettre plus jamais en colère ce qu'il a
fait donc c'était pas du tout
moi je revendique le droit de se mettre
en colère il faut des vrais débats c'est
y a de moi ce qu'il disait de TPMP qu'il
est l'héritier de droit de réponse et
vous voyez j'ai fait un truc ce week-end
j'ai tweeté bon je suis embrouillé que
tout le monde ce weekend à cause de toi
mais
il y avait du jeu plein de gens qui
faisaient
[Applaudissements]
les émissions de droit de réponse donc
mais en fait les gens ont été choqués
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait ils ont été
choqués de cette espèce de liberté de
ton existait pour retrouver dans quel
mont mardi à l'époque et au fond quand
on voit pardon je le dis voilà avec la
franchise mais qu'est-ce que c'est
chiant les débat politique aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire que en fait c'est chiant
c'est normal on dérange on dérange on le
sait on dérange France Inter on dérange
mais le service public on dérange les
autres groupes et les autres choses
on dérange les autres journalistes alors
il y en a qui sont fair-play mais
entendu je la c'est toujours il y en a
des bruits et des mauvais partout mais
voilà et à la limite moi ça me dérange
pas de déranger